to believe in but also teaching the
companions
what to believe in and what to expect
from Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And so these beliefs with respect to
luck and bad luck, it made its way all
the way to the Kaa. So imagine
there are these seven ceremonious lots
there at the Cabba.
Each bag has three arrows without their
heads
in the bags.
And one arrow would have do not do it.
And the other will have do it. And the
third will be empty.
And another one will be with respect to
lineage.
Lineage. A woman has a child. Whose
child is this? We don't know whose child
it is. We don't know whose father
who's who's who's the father of
this ch child. So what do they do? They
have another three arrows in a bag
written.
They have he is of the lineage of the
asker or he is to be adopted by the
person asking or he is not of that
person's lineage. And so there were sed
there at the Kaba. There were quote
unquote devotees there at the Cabba. And
if you
were un
clear with respect to whose child this
is or if you were unclear on whether or
not you you'd to go on this
journey, take this travel,
then
you would
ask these sticks.
So you would go there, you would pay the
seda, you would pay the devotees that
are in charge of these lots. You give
them money and then they would make all
of these prayers to their idols and they
would have you draw these lots and they
would base incredible things on them.
And now
the way that a shaitan works is he
cannot change reality itself. He can
only interfere with a person's
perception of reality. And so what does
he do? If a person goes to a fortune
teller and one thing out of a hundred
things that that fortune teller said
happened to be correct by by way of
chance,
then a shaitan will make the person
hyperfocus on that one thing that was
correct and ignore all of the 99 other
blunders and incorrect things. And a
shan does the same thing with respect to
the Muslim.
It will come at a person or people when
they receive their messenger. They are
looking with a microscope.
Shaitan will have them only notice
something that is perceived to be as a
mistake and ignore the other 99
correct and qualitative things etc.
And this is how a shaitan was placing
his fear into the hearts of the mushri
at that time. The idoltors
and this is why Allah refers to them as
having worshiped a shaitan because they
feared when he told them to fear and
they loved whom he told them to love and
they hated whom they he told them to
hate. And this is the nature of worship.
This is the nature of worship.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam he said
so they were superstitious about times,
places, numbers, people, animals etc.
And so the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam
tried to or did eradicate all of
these superstitions from their from
their hearts by the will of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. So he said
that all superstitions with respect to
owls
are not real. They're not true. What is
an owl? What's the significance of an
owl? It's an animal that flies around at
night and eats mice and snakes. That's
it. That is the extent of it. Nothing
else. It's not some wise creature. It is
not the incarnation
of dead or murdered or wronged souls.
What is a black cat? It is a cat that is
black.
That is it.
What happens when a black cat walks
across your path? Nothing.
That's it. A black cat walked across
your path. A white cat walked across
your path. And notice how superstitions
are usually negative,
right? Because the purpose behind these
superstitions when a shaitan teaches
them to people is to kind of instill
this
very
uncomfortable feeling and
with respect to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala as if Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
only has bad things for us in store
right and as if to make us expect only
the bad and the worst of things.
He says well
they used to believe that the month of
Safar which is the second month of the
calendar they would believe that that
was an unlucky month.
If you
were to get married you should not get
married in Safar. If you're going to
build a house, you should not build that
house during in the month of Safar. If
you want to go on a on a journey or
travel, Safar is not the month to do
that in because that is unlucky, right?
And anytime a person is unaware
or uneducated with respect to the
rulings and the sunnah of the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam. These
superstitions may make their way back
into a person's heart but take an
Islamic image to them. So for instance,
if we go back to the issue of the
drawing of lots that they used to do,
right? They would go and they they want
to go on a journey or they didn't know
what to do in a particular issue. So
they would you know go and pay the
devote at the shrine or at the the seda
or do it at on their own and they would
draw one of these lots and this would
help them to make their decision. All
right. This is a type of shik and Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala refers to this asan.
It is a filth from the handiwork of a
shan himself.
Now this can take on a kind of Islamic
an Islamic outward appearance.
How? So for instance, a person is having
a problem or a person is unaware as to
what they should do or what decision
they should make. They take the musaf
and they think of a particular issue and
they have a particular question. They
open the musaf to a random place
and whatever verse they find there then
that's the verse.
The scholars of Islam
have
mentioned that this is a type of
Islam. Just because a person is using
the musf to do it doesn't make it
correct and permissible. Doesn't make it
Islamic. the same beliefs and
superstitions are behind this that I can
somehow peak into the future by way of
randomly opening the mus
or I say if if something good is going
to happen or something bad is going to
happen that's going to be judged by the
next person that walks walks through the
door or the first phone call I get right
these kinds of things are the same
belief system that was in the time of he
says
he says and there is no
nothing
significant about the positioning of
the stars.
the positioning of the stars.
The concept of astrology
that the stars
reflect or foretell by their positions
what will happen on the earth.
or that a particular star when it
appears it will bring rain with it and
when it disappears
it will not rain. Right? Or astrological
symbols. We look at the stars, we see
their positions and we start to imagine
that if this star lines up with this
star under these circumstances then it
means this. Astrology. We call it
astrology, right? The prophet
sallall.aii Wasam
says
[Silence]
he says whoever learns a portion of
astrology
then this person has learned of the
disciplines of magic.
a that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
prohibited in Islam.
And for this reason he says
if the ideas of astrology are brought up
then do not delve into those beliefs.
And so here in this narration he says
no. And then he says
what is al you know I believe that the
Palestinian
brothers around that perhaps grew
up in Palestine
as I did would remember we have the
concept of but it's not a we call it a
right
and we actually had a whole many
kind of fairy tales of the adventures of
a young boy named
we called it
and it's a bunch of stories about howun
this young very clever boy he was always
pursued by this this monster and he
would always outsmart this and how he
outsmarted her how he would swindle her
and she would want to try to eat him and
try to you know use his bones for
this and that and and so the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam here in this
narration says
but this doesn't mean that doesn't
necessarily exist. It doesn't exist in
the way that they believed in in the
time ofah. So perhaps we will discuss
that at another time. Allah Subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
I am a son.
[Silence]
H I
Allah
will
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Muslim
itch. forch.
[Silence]
foram.
for
[Silence]
Alhamdulill.
verses that we are all familiar with
that are the first verses that any of us
learn from the Quran.
These are the verses that Allah
Subhanahu Waaala
found
fit and most appropriate
to begin his book, the final revelation
and his final book to mankind.
The greatest of all miracles
that has ever been given to any prophet
or messenger.
and the book that would be humanity's
resource
and their rope extended from the heavens
down into the earth into their hands.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
deemed that the first thing any reader
of the Quran upon opening the Quran
should read
is
Alhamdulillah.
And notice there
the purity
of this belief system
and how the human being is to proceed.
not only proceed with reading the
remaining the remainder of the Quran and
that all subsequent verses that the
reader
sees of the Quran are to be understood
through the lens of these first verses.
But this is how a person is to proceed
through this world.
We are to proceed before we do
something. We begin with the ethos, the
belief, the statement of
and upon completion of that and when
looking to the past we are to say
alhamdulill
this is how the Muslim
this is how the Muslim walks that
fine line between hope and fear. fear
between what he wants and what Allah
wants for him, between what he is to do
and what Allah is to do with him.
It is all on the scales of
that's the first lesson of the Quran.
What do these words mean? Allah
Subhanahu Wa'ta'ala says,
I begin in the name of Allah. I begin in
all of the names of Allah.
So what is the meaning of the name
Allah?
Allah
means the one who is worshiped out of
love and exaltation rightfully.
Allah
literally means the only rightful one
who is worshiped out of love and
exaltation.
That is Allah.
Why is Allah rightful to that worship?
because he is alman alim
alman
the generally and expansive the
extensively
merciful
and the particularly merciful. You
notice that ale
in the Quran is to always follow alman
because alman is more broad more
general. No one and nothing of the
creation of Allah is ex is excluded
from the
from the implications of alman.
Alheim is an additional portion of mercy
that is allotted to those who are
believers.
Those who will not just be shown mercy
in this life but in the hereafter. those
who have obtained
eternal mercy from Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
So he is alman alim. What's interesting
about the name Alman,
the way that the word is structured,
it articulates
an unimeaginable,
unfathomable,
unmitigated,
expansive
mercy that is beyond imagination.
This is the meaning of alman.
the one who is more merciful than
anyone's imagination.
His mercy extends far past
the imagination of anyone.
And what's very interesting about
this name of Allah Alman
is that if you look into the history
of the Arabs and you look at the names
that people had, you would see Abdim a
lot a slave to ale. You would see Abd
Aziz a slave to al Aziz just today
they named the Arabs named their
children Abd Abdul Rahim and Abd Aziz
and they named their children Abdullah
and they named their children
but you will scarcely find the name
Abdul Rahman.
This became a proprietary
name used only by the Muslim.
Why?
Well, the Arabs understood that the
structure of this word alman,
immeasurably
merciful,
one who has a mercy that knows no
bounds.
that this was too extreme of a
description of mercy even for Allah
himself.
They couldn't imagine that anyone
would be described as a
not even Allah himself has that amount
of mercy.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala made
one of his primary names Alman and he
made belief in the name Alman
a defining feature amongst the Muslim
that we believe in the eternal boundless
mercy of Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala.
And so the prophet sallall.aii Wasallam
tells us
the most beloved of names to Allah are
Abdullah and Abdman
and Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala tells us
worship Allah or worship alman
All of these are names of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And so it became a point
that we would affirm the name alman for
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. And the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam went to
great lengths
to articulate the level of mercy that
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has.
And when describing himself rising above
his creation, rising above his throne,
his throne being the ceiling of
of paradise, Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
always used the the name Alman.
Alman rose above his creation, rose
above his throne. Subhanahu wa'ta'ala.
This is to articulate that not one thing
that Allah has brought into existence
exists outside
of the implications of Alman. Everything
exists.
Everything exists.
Muslim, non-Muslim,
animal, inanimate object, the heavens
themsel
themselves and the earth
all exist under Alman
and none is exempt from his mercy.
And so
the one who is particularly merciful,
he is alman to all, but he is ale to the
believers.
Those who hold in their hearts,
those who uphold
in their lives. Those who accept and
receive the messengers of Allah,
those who worship Allah alone without
any without any partners, they
are to have an additional portion of
mercy. Even on top of alman, even on top
of the mercy that is received
from existing
under the canopy of alman.
It's really breathtaking actually to
imagine the extents
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala's mercy.
Our prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
tells us in the narration of Salman
Pharisee and others alkari Muslim
he says says,
"Butch
[Silence]
The prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
tells us that Allah has designated
a portion of mercy that he will show to
this creation and the people in the
hereafter.
And he tells us that he has divided
those mercies into a hundred portions
and he has taken one portion
and he has placed that one portion on
the earth between the creation. He said,
"And every mercy shared or experienced
or shown by any creation of Allah
from the inception of the creation of
the heavens and the earth until the day
of judgment, every mercy
is shared amongst those creation of
Allah from that one portion.
every mercy. He said even animals
when they show mercy ex instinctively
to their offspring they are drawing from
that one portion of mercy
from the beginning of creation until the
end. All the mercy that is shown in this
life is from that one portion of mercy.
He said and he has reserved the other 99
portions of mercy
that he will show his believing
servants on the day of judgment.
Subhanahu wa ta'ala. unimaginable
unimaginable
the amount and the extent of the mercy
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala on the day
of judgment if all of this mercy is one
portion imagine that 99 other portions
of mercy that Allah has to show his
creation.
The prophet sallallah.aii wasallam once
saw a woman who had been separated from
her child. The narration is in Sah
Bkari. And when she found her child, she
ran up and hugged this child very
tightly, dearly.
And the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
said to the companions that were with
him,
"Do you see that mother there? Could you
imagine her taking that child and
placing that child in fire?
He said of of course not. We could not
imagine
this woman who was so
you know so attached to that child to
place her child in fire. He said,
he said, "By Allah, Allah is more
merciful
to his believing servant than this woman
is to her child."
The prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
tells us and Muslim this narration was a
narration that Ibas
one of the scholars and reciters of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam and
one of the first to ever believe in him
in the days of Mecca Abdullahbas
Abu Abdman
he tells us an irreration in Muslim in
the book of Eman
he says I know
the last person
that will be delivered from the fire and
admitted into paradise.
He said a man
who will be on the bridge as trying to
cross it.
He said, "And on his journey across the
and people will cross the surat with the
speed and the and the balance based
on their deeds in this life. If they
were fast to good deeds, then they will
be fast across this bridge." The prophet
sallallah.aii Wasam tells us that some
people will cross this bridge in the
blink of an eye. Others will cross this
bridge
at the speed of lightning. Others at
the speed of a fast horse. Others will
walk. Others will run. And some will
crawl on their bellies across this
surat.
a bridge that in order to enter into
paradise, you have to cross this bridge.
And this bridge
is
bridging over the hellfire.
And there are hooks meat hooks that
will swing across and knock people in to
the fire. Those who are deserving,
the prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
tells us that the last person across
that bridge will be a man that got there
tediously.
On some portions he was able to balance
enough to walk a few steps
and in some parts he had to crawl and
scoot on his belly across this bridge.
And in other cases, the fire would slap
him in the face on occasions as he is
crossing this bridge
until he reaches the end.
This man will then turn to the hellfire
after placing both feet on the other
side and said,
He said, "Alhamdulillah that Allah has
rid me of you.
Allah has given me something that he has
given no other person this gift of of
anyone else. I am the lucky I am the
most fortunate person in existence."
And then
an oasis will appear in front of him. An
oasis, a place where there's some
running water in a tree.
And he will stare at this oasis and
stare. He's not been permitted to enter
paradise yet. He believes that being
saved from the hellfire, I'm not going
to ask for anything else. But the human
being has a very short memory. The human
being is in desperate need of Allah. And
so this oasis will appear and he will
stare at this oasis and stare at it and
then he will say
you will say oh Allah please let me go
into this small oasis here. Let me drink
from that water and be in its shade. I
promise if you give me that I won't ask
for anything else. You won't hear from
me again.
And so Allah will take his promise that
he will not ask for anything else if
Allah lets him go into that oasis.
And so he will.
But when he gets to the oasis, there's
another oasis ahead of him. This it's
clearly better than the one that he's
in. But he will drink from the water and
he will be under its shade and he will
stare at this other oasis. It's nicer.
It's bigger. It's more comfortable. It
smells better.
And so he will muster up the audacity to
ask Allah to give him that oasis.
And Allah will say,
"Didn't you promise me that you would
not ask me for anything else if I gave
you this one?" He said, "Yes, I did. But
I promise I will not ask for anything.
This is all I want. This just this one."
And so Allah will take his word that he
will not ask for anything else. Allah
will then allow him to go to this next
oasis. And he'll enter this oasis. And
there's just one problem with this
oasis. There's another oasis. You see
that's it's clearly better than the
first two. But he will drink from its
water and he will be in its shade. and
he's staring at this next third better
superior oasis and he will then muster
up the courage to ask Allah to give him
that last oasis. This final third oasis
is right outside the gates of paradise.
And so he will ask Allah and Allah will
say,
"You are so treacherous. Didn't you
promise me? Didn't I take your word,
your solemn oath that if I gave you this
one, you wouldn't ask for anything else?
He will say you did. But I promise that
if you give me this one, you won't hear
anything out of me again. You won't hear
a peep out of me. Just this last thing,
this one thing.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala will
allow him to advance to this third
oasis. But as soon as he enters this
third oasis, the problem with it is
evidence
and that is that it is right at the
gates of paradise. And now he smells
paradise. He can peek into paradise a
little bit and he hears what's going on
in there.
And he will continue to listen and
continue to smell and continue to peek
and crane his neck until finally he will
ask Allah, "Please let me just go into
paradise. Just let me go in there.
Just give it to me. Let me go in there,
please."
And Allah will say,
"You are so treacherous.
Minka, what will get you to stop asking
for more? He will say, and then he will
say, "Will it satisfy you and quill your
thirst for more if I give you
the likes of the dunya and twice fold in
other narrations, if I give you the
likes of the dunya and 10 times the best
that the dunya had to offer." And he
will say,
He said, "Now you're making fun of me.
Are you making fun of me and you are
what do you want with a a little
creature me to make fun of?"
And the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
laughed and mentioned that that is the
last person that will enter paradise.
The last that is the least of the people
of paradise.
Subhanah.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
All
Muslim.
Allah
Sudan Kashmir.
[Silence]
Allah.
All
[Silence]
inch.
Allah.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Sh.
Holy
diplomat.
[Silence]
Stand shouldertosh shoulder. Align your
shoulders and feet with the shoulders
and feet of your two neighbors, both men
and women. They line their rows up in
exactly the same way. Please double
check your phones. Ensure that they are
silent. Ensure that your row or your
part of the row is as straight as
possible. The prophet sallall.aii
wasallam tells us
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Amen.
inel.
[Silence]
All
even though
[Silence]
Allah.
Alhamdulillah.
Fore!
Foreign! Foreign!
Amen.
Fore! Foreign! Foreign!
[Silence]
All
me
Allah Oh,
exhale.
[Silence]
Allahel.
The Lord. Oh,
the
[Silence]
Step.
Brothers and sisters, asalam alaikum.
Couple of reminders.
Fudgerama
is at 5 a.m. Fajama is 5:00 a.m.
Inshallah. there's a mil potluck
tomorrow at Ka Awaken Park and it starts
at 7 a.m. and lasts until 100 p.m. So
come prepared for the hiking and I think
there's the coordinators are
looking for some confirmations. So
please look up on our website, see if
you can sign up and make sure your name
is recognized.
Also want to congratulate one of our
youths. She is in our Sunday program.
Her name is Stella Morrison. She earned
the third place in the 400 meter race at
the Phoenix Invitational meet. Takir,
congratulations to her parents
for that achievement.
MCCT summer program will start in June
June the 1st and will last until July
1st. So please make plans your vacation
plans or summer programs accordingly. It
will be for the ages 9 plus and the
theme will be mas ala and that is going
to be run by Imam Ali inshallah and the
kids will benefit tremendously. So
please make sure you make the plans to
to join.
Please donate generously on the way out.
Also one other achievement that the
community has made the Rahma Academy the
Arizona state tax that we have been
asking for. Alhamdulillah here at
Bilalam we have achieved $125,000
mark
again we have achieved $125,000
mark for the community. It's tremendous
thanks to you and this process does not
stop it. You can continue donating and
if it is not for this year, it will be
the next year. So, brother Jabber can
explain to you how this works. But the
process continues. We'll keep asking for
this. It helps our to our program at the
Rahma Academy.
Donate generously on the way out.
[Silence]
There you go.
You made me cry today.
Mr. Fas, how are you sir?
[Arabic recitation]
The wires.
We need another extra wire. That's all.
I'll figure it out.